A lot of unhappiness comes about in this world
because we can't let other people know
what we mean clearly enough.
One of the philosophers who can help us
with our communication problems
is Ludwig Wittgenstein.
He was a recluse.
He had a stutter, paused for ages in the middle
of his sentences and had a habit of
storming out
if he didn't like what people were saying.
It was weirdly the ideal background
for someone intent on studying how easily
communication between people goes wrong.
Ludwig Wittgenstein
was born Vienna in 1889.
The youngest child of a wealthy,
highly cultured
but domineering steel magnate.
Three of Ludwig's four brothers took their own lives,
and Ludwig himself was frequently
troubled by suicidal thoughts.
When he was young, he was interested in engineering.
After studying at Cambridge,
his father died and he inherited a lot
of money.
He gave it all away,
mainly to his already very rich relatives
and went to live in spartan solitude
in Norway.
Then he started writing a book published in 1921
called Tractatus Logico-Philosophicus.
It was a short, beautiful
and baffling work.
The big question that Wittgenstein
asks in it is:
How do human beings
manage to communicate ideas to one another?
And his answer,
which felt revolutionary,
is that language works by triggering
within us
pictures of how things are in the world.
Wittgenstein thought of this
while reading a newspaper article about
a Paris court case in which,
in order to explain with greater efficacy, the details of
an accident that had taken place a road junction,
the court had arranged for the accident
to be reproduced visually
using model cars and pedestrians.
It was a Eureka moment.
In Wittgenstein's view words enables us to
make pictures of facts.
To say: The palm tree is by the shore,
paints a rapid sketch
that like the model lets another person see
the situation in their mind and understand.
We're constantly
swapping pictures between us.
But the Paris court needed to resort to an actual model
for a very important reason.
Because on the whole,
we're very bad at managing to
make good pictures in the minds of others.
Communication typically goes wrong
because other people have, as we put it,
the wrong picture of what we're meaning.
It can take an age for two people to
realize divergences over quite basic things.
Problems of communication typically start because
we don't have a clear and accurate enough picture
of what we mean in our own heads.
We say quite meaningless or modeled
or unelaborated things
which therefore can go nowhere in the minds of others.
There's another danger:
That we read more meaning into the words of others
than they ever intended or than is warranted.
You tell your partner you had a conversation with
an interesting person at the hotel reception.
The picture in your mind
is an innocent one.
But your partner swiftly forms
a very different impression.
The Tractatus is a plea
by a very taciturn, silent and precise
Austrian philosopher
to speak more carefully and less impulsively.
As he famously put it:
"Wovon man nicht sprechen kann,
darüber muss man schweigen."
When he published it,
Wittgenstein thought somewhat grandly
that the Tractatus was the last work of philosophy
that would ever need to be written.
So he looked around for how to fill the rest of his life.
He turned to architecture and spent a couple of years
designing a house for his sister in Vienna.
He spent ages getting the
door handles and radiotors right.
Very late on in the project, he got increasingly
bothered about the ceiling in one of the rooms
and came to the conclusion
that is was too low.
At immense inconvenience to everyone,
he insisted on having it raised
by three centimeters.
It made all the difference, he thought.
Then, in 1929
Wittgenstein suddenly returned to Cambridge
and to philosophy
because he realized he had some new things
to say about language and communication.
And so he began to write a second book
published posthumously,
and that we know know as
Philosophical Investigations.
Instead of thinking that
language is only just about pictures,
he developed the idea
that language is like a kind of tool
that we use to play different games,
which doesn't literally mean
games, more patterns of intentions.
So if a parent says
to a frightened child:
"Don't worry - everything's gonna to be fine",
they can't know it really will be fine.
They aren't playing
the Rational Prediction From Available Facts Game.
They're playing another game:
The Words as an Instrument of
Comfort and Security Game
Wittgenstein's point is that
all kinds of misunderstandings arise
when we don't see
which kind of game someone is involved in.
If one's partner says:
"You never help me. You're so unreliable."
The natural inclination might be
to hear this as a part of
a Stating the Facts Game;
like saying:
The battle of Waterloo was in 1815.
So one might respond by citing facts about
how actually you got the car insurance yesterday,
and you bought some vegetables at lunch time, too.
But actually,
this person is involved in a different language game.
They're using words
not to capture facts.
They're playing The Help and Reassurance Game.
So in the language game, they're involved in,
"You never help" means
"I want you to be more nurturing."
Working out the game in question,
is, Wittgenstein realized,
key to good communication.
In the Philosophical Investigations
Wittgenstein also wanted to draw attention
to how much of our self-understanding
depends on the words of others,
on languages that have
developed publicly and communally
over many centuries
long before we're born.
For example, on Sunday afternoon
I might fall prey to a worried, confused mood
as I think about the week ahead
and everything I've got to do.
My ability to know this very private side of myself
and to help others know me
will be hugely enhanced if I have to hand a word
that's been around a while:
Angst.
A word which was helpfully formulated
by the philosopher
Kierkegaard in 19th century, Copenhagen.
Words like angst or also
nostalgia,
melancholy or
ambivalent
and many others
help us to name elusive areas of our own experience.
Language is a public tool
for the understanding of private life.
The richness of the language we're exposed to
is therefore really important to our self-knowledge.
Reading many books
gives us tools with which to help to know
who we are.
Though a lot of Wittgenstein's philosophy
is deeply complicated,
it's underpinned by a desire always to be helpful.
The task of philosophy, said Wittgenstein,
is to show the fly the way out of the fly bottle.
The particular fly bottle, he was interested in,
was language.
And before his death from cancer in 1951,
he managed to let out for us
a lot of word flies
usefully for us all.